boah ich hasse diesen effekt mehr wird
man immer echt ein bisschen übel er ist
am harmlosesten ich bin langsamkeit der
lauge preis ab das ist mit das geht ab
ihr sohn max unter sich kommt zu einer
folge guetta und zusammen mit - tut weh
das tut ak der dude dessen tastatur laut
ist und falls ihr euch fragt herr schon
wieder get down
ich habe irgendwie todes bock auf diesem
spielmodus gerade ich hoffe sein und es
lag dass du hast schon todes punkte und
wir sind beide nicht genügt das sollten
wir vielleicht noch einen assist oder
james irvine ist man immer genau hier
ist es sein sondern als technik eingehen
ich vergesse sein weil grad bei guitar
und ist es halt mega es sind wenn man
getötet wird und wo bei franz nicht
dürften ja eigentlich viele leute kennen
ich nehme immer mal wieder mit franz auf
mich sind wirklich regelmäßig zu
wir arbeiten gemeinsam an dingen aber
dann kommt es aber vermehrt vor dass ihr
zusammen aufnehmen weil es einfach viel
greifen nach unten lächelt was man wie
heißt du hast du vor wie sie in der
ersten reihe in der ersten runde fast
1000 punkte
und wenn ich zusammen an irgendwelchen
dingen arbeiten dann nämlich immer öfter
miteinander auf weil wir dann halt viel
kontakt miteinander haben aber gerade
arbeiten wie ein ding und das heißt es
passieren dinge aber das kündige ich ja
schon länger an das erste taten folgen
er ist ja richtig gute sachen ja aber
wir geben den leuten keine tipps was es
ist oder nicht wird ein weiterer klar
gerne ich habe nämlich noch gar keinen
block eingesammelt jetzt vielleicht
gleich thermal direct 3 auf einem haufen
alter und der stirbt nicht mal das war
richtig jackpot hier dinge dran
so bringt dann eigentlich auch nicht
sehr wenig sind die einzigen premium
sind ja gut das ist schade unterstützen
server und uns in dem ihr euch fragt ob
müssen
okay halt das glaub ich nicht wirklich
freuen
ich bin sie folglich auch sie war heute
sehr produktiv insgesamt das video kommt
natürlich wieder voll spät weil ich so
im verteiler von peter aufgenommen
ich wollte direkt weiter arbeiten mit
franz aber daraus wurde leider nichts
also doch was am arbeiten wurde was aber
daraus rechts zeichen videos machen
ja ich war ganz ums patermann bestimmt
zu 666 blogs play cool allerdings
natural ich kann mir nicht mehr so
würden diese runde noch nicht so super
viele ich kann mir wurden aber auch ein
park gezogen ja das sei wie auch immer
das gefühl ist einfach punkte abgezogen
werden wenn man runterfällt oder so ich
weiß nicht ja muss man aus hessen das
herunterfallen fixe na gut das würde
erklären weshalb man vielleicht bisschen
zumindest vorsichtig so defensiv spielen
würde
weil manchmal mache ich einfach spring
ich runter wenn ich nicht mehr so
richtig cool aus spielmodus also ich bin
relativ gerne denn das sei und deshalb
müsst ihr den aushalten
irgendwie habe ich das manchmal so dass
ich schrie modi richtig liebe und dann
müssen die leute die 30 also sie müssen
natürlich
wir sehen wollen müssen sie dann 30 mal
hintereinander anschauen hier mit seinem
lieblingslied irgendwann hast du es dann
genau jetzt hat er mich getötet
ja ich glaube ich habe gerade keins
verloren ich bin ich sicher ich will den
arbeiten 500 ist kommen machte schon
jemand konkurrenz aber in der ersten
runde fast 1000 zwar ist schon ist es
war so als hätte ich noch nie hat
einfach glück kann ich nicht
und jetzt kommt's mir wären denn dann so
eine schöne freunde so eine schande
ich habe extra herz ich finde es ist
wirklich teilweise ein bisschen schwer
hier auf dieser karte
ja weil du hast selben oben diese ganze
bäume die übel viele herzen abziehen
wenn du da runter spielen und dann
kommen nur so vereinzelt blöcke
du kommst gar nicht an die an dieser
kette blöcke rendez-vous so nervig jaja
geheißen so ein krankenhaus in münster
sind unter wasser lampen wenn man es
genau sind unter wasser lampen gz 18
richtig boah ich hasse diesen effekt
wird mir immer ich ein bisschen übel es
am harmlosesten ich finde langsamkeit
der langen pass abfangen könnte was ist
mit dem polo seite fängt es wieder daran
jetzt nicht mehr staub sauer das ja ich
verstehe das auch nicht irgendwie tut
mir leid freunde ist wieder da irgendwie
mein mikrofon spielen zurzeit ein
bisschen rum
es ging nicht mehr aufgehört zu
funktionieren einfach schippmann jetzt
schon wieder so hörst du mich hörst du
mich jetzt wieder normal dass das xlr
kabel austauschen hat noch ein anderes
hier auch so ein schild alter
es geht mir einfach in der aufnahme das
mikrofon kaputt sein lassen konnte
er kann es sein dass irgendwie gar keine
glocke sind ich sehe jetzt gab meinen
ersten und bin schon auf der hälfte oder
so ja irgendwie sicher auch nicht
wirklich tatsächlich wobei man erkennt
die auch richtig schlecht auf der karte
herr zwischen den fenstern zu lassen
sondern have four wheel alter ab drei
jetzt gesehen da unten saß ich sehe hier
und mein erstes grad um 400 lücke unter
mir und erhält ist vollkommen tricky
irgendwie auf gott
ich habe jetzt meinen ersten block alter
151 gegeben auf dieser karte ich bin
glaube ich noch keinmal tödliche
runtergefallen
also nix wie schon vor weit unten vorher
wir übrigens auch für franzen gespielt
gibt es auf seinem kanal glaube ich
nehme ja sogar schon gestern ja auch get
down und da haben wir die challenge
gespielt den revolver im stream hey
freunde wir bringen die gitter und
lecture aufnehmen könnte irgendwie mal
das leck plug in sein mikrophon während
auf der finne sekunde
aber da war einfach aus oder wie man ihn
einfach so diese distanz gesetzt diese
winzer was ist denn das
arbeit ist es okay und bloß lag todes
und vermischt ok
80 86 der einen typ einfach 1300 meinen
spind komplett alleine 280 20 level
konnten längst und sich nicht
30 level würde sich nur lohnen weil das
feuer auf den sport kriegen könnte
aber der rest ist vor allem finde ich
doof irgendwie dies enchantment system
dadurch dass das hier häufig liegt
einfach passiert ist todes oft dass man
nicht nicht wirklich entscheiden kann so
dass die kasachen techno oder man hat
eingang in zeiten als man ja genau weil
die beiden brauchst zehn versuche bist
du das bist du das ding raus gezogen
hast
links interne und dann das ist todes
nervig stufe 2 man kann wir auch mehr
verzaubern die sachen ja ich hab dann 1
haltbarkeit einzelnen rücksturz 1 auf
mensch wert bekommen ich habe sharp 12
auf meine schwer passt man keines öfters
fertig
ich hätte schon hier
ich versteh's nicht aber man kann sachen
tatsächlich mehrfach verzögert
er hat noch geschafft so mein handy die
karte geht sogar einigermaßen klar für
mich aber ich finde ja zu viel wasser
aber ich hab ja im bogen aus dem weg
gehen weil ich also taktische
gleichgültigkeit ist war ola erlaubt
oder was meinst du locker hinter mir
aber jemand und masken der flames ort
und das liquid cooled alter experte
aufgetreten typ der wollte mich mit
lederhandschuhen seiten was mit dem jahr
der hamburger wie er hat einfach nur
leder harnisch an und in der helmand
importieren ich habe ein problem
transaktion an ja ich bin im grunde
könnte es mich raus ziehen
aber wer das team dann für 100 coins
welches machen gehen auf fast 6 das
vorhaben nicht da bin ich da bin ich da
bin ich ganz schön wichtig falls das
team war dann möglich dafür gerecht
bestraft werden ich warte mal mit du
hast noch nicht was mich in diesem stall
die reihe kriege ich das auto kommt man
nicht aus da gibt's zurzeit ihren
letzten auftritt ich hatte auch über den
panik weil der sind diese komischen
unsichtbar kenne ja genau diese burial
flopp
ich glaube ich habe von jemanden ich
habe feuerwehrtechnik
ockert in zweikämpfen dagegen nicht so
gut
ich werde mich erst mal nicht einmischen
und den vorwurf des teams weiter
entschärfen
wie kann man eigentlich so viel ich habe
sharp 12 mw gar nichts ich hab feuer des
killer höchststand der hat gold äpfel
gegessen zwei stück der in den schatten
bot nämlich an
ich habe so viele sachen solar okay ich
bin jetzt der dritte spieler dann höre
ich jetzt kriegst du kannst du dich
schnell folgen da machen einfach schnell
finale presto sind schon alle weg sind
schon allerdings ich suche mir noch ein
schönes schwert verbrennung oder egal
was sie für richtig hält und dann fällt
mir einfach mit allem was wir drauf
haben
das beweisen wie viel text bringt man
eigentlich nicht
der server ja aber ich konnte dich
geschlagen und dann an die platine pony
passierte ja das ist schon relativ stark
dass ich jetzt habe ich gesagt ich weiß
nicht und weiß dass am wasser bist und
ab dann mit meinem chef fischfest
angegriffen
wer gut du kannst besser ausweichen ist
das die entscheidung freude ist das ein
schock ich werde jetzt nicht die pussy
machen hier im wasser und untertauchen
ist so lange weiter wie sich dann aus
hallo kinder und zuschauer als ob und
auch dass ich dachte jetzt ist
letztendlich doch jetzt wirst du im
wasser
das wird nichts mehr und mit der combo
des lebens ich hatte eigentlich herzen
hast du noch ca wahrscheinlich viele
vielleicht sechs okay aber es war
insgesamt eine lustige runde mit
behinderten zwischenfällen und einem
interessanten endkampf wären und ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen check-up
franz aus und bis zum nächsten mal